john what up man it's garyvee listen  when you're 23  society's trying to tell you you have to  figure it out but i got a big news for  you no 23 year old had it figured the  [ __ ] out either like you got lots of  time i think the next seven years is a  good time to go high risk high reward  like just live humble the only reason  kids get caught is you want to buy dumb  [ __ ] to impress other people if you  don't buy dumb [ __ ] then you can do  anything go taste things go figure out  what you like to do because the level of  hard work it takes to actually be  successful is a lot easier when you  actually like something and the reality  is too many people are [ __ ] lazy  because they want it too fast so you  need to figure out something you  actually like so you put in the hours  because nothing great comes easy